if you find the right man
at 35. you get in a relationship at 35.
when are you going to think about having
a child you know that can happen in 6
can happen in two years time that's not
a general calendar and we don't planify
our life day by day that things just
happens and I just don't feel like I'm
less valuable than 20 years old I'm just
different so did you know one out of
three women under 30 have fertility
issues one out of everything our food is
different today
so like so I I know but I'm saying for
the right guy so if you found the guy
that that you would have a kid with like
that that's more of a risk when you're
older yeah it's great to go without 20
years old if you just won't think about
me as a baby machine it's free to go
either 20 years older one girl I'm fine
exactly